Russia is a tricky tricky country and
it's made all the harder because we
think we know Russia because we think we
at least the Cold War generation thinks
we know the Soviet Union we have lots of
stereotypes that were not even aware of
and the new generation of policymakers
has no experience with Russia Russia
wasn't even on their radar screen so you
have a real lacuna of experts who are
thinking about the country Russia is
today not the country Russia was in
nineteen eighty or ninety 90 or 2000 and
who are genuinely expert that means we
need to proceed with real care it would
be wonderful if President Obama could
find a way simultaneously to give Russia
some of the acknowledgement it's so
craves as a great power but at the same
time draw some real red lines because
that's got to be our policy we have to
make very clear very clear where those
lines are but we also have to listen to
the Russians and the Russians have
actually been pretty Frank about what
they thought were red lines and they
they were very clear with respect to
Georgia that they were going to look at
Isetta and at South Ossetia and Abkhazia
those were enclaves that they were not
going to let Georgia take over we have
to pay attention when they say that we
have to treat that as we would if China
or the EU or any other major power told
us these are our vital interests we have
to pay attention because we expect them
to pay attention to us we also have to
acknowledge where in fact the current
Russian government has improved a lot of
the Russian people and we have to avoid
looking at the current implosion of the
Russian economy and thinking well that's
great they're going to go down again
that's trouble for us that's major
trouble because in the end the Russian
government is not going to stand by and
lose